as sasha johnson fights her life in
hospital her friends
family and fellow activists want to know
why she was a victim of a shooting in
south london
police were called to a party in peckham
in the early hours of sunday morning
after reports of gunfire they don't
believe that sasha was the target of the
attack
but the political group she was involved
with say she received multiple death
threats linked to her work
sasha was a leading figure in the black
lives matter protest last year
as black people we're saying that enough
is enough we're declaring a state of
emergency in a black community
not just here in the uk but worldwide
iman airton lives locally
and knows sasha through their campaign
work i am just devastated for her and
her family and it's scary
you don't want to admit that but it's
scary you don't
you don't want to hear these types of
stories and especially about someone
with such a big heart who actually
dedicates her life for equality this is
why we know sasha because she has a big
heart and because she is a fierce
strong black woman and an anti-racist
activist i do believe that this
sheds a greater light on the issue
centered around
serious crime violence and i think that
is the new conversation that we should
now be focused on
that conversation's again on the agenda
for the mayor of london
it's no consolation to sasha's families
the fact that huge progress has been
made and has been made
you know gun crime is down violent crime
is done but the fact is
sasha is currently fighting for a life
in intensive care
emotions will raw at a vigil near the
hospital where she is recovering after
an operation
people here are gathered to show support
for someone they see as their sister
in the battle for racial equality
they're spoken about her
as a mother and a friend as well as
someone who inspired them to take to the
streets
to march for what they believe in what a
beautiful
what a beautiful talent
and to think that she was shot in the
head
[Music]
you know i i've cursed some bad words
i'm not gonna
repeat here just saying why
why a woman a peace a woman
who had a vision those here are praying
that sasha will return home
and to campaigning soon this community
is distraught
and in search of answers shinki maurike
sky news south london